tu as bien dormir assez vite coco fermer
les yeux est entré dans le monde des
rêves je dors bien je suis réveillé
techniquement tu es en train de dormir
dans sa chambre mais tu es à l'extérieur
de ton rêve
donc chaque personne a sa propre scène
sur laquelle vous préférez c'est ça mais
c'est une zone strictement interdite à
tous les rêveurs imaginez que votre aide
puisse se réaliser
hu
même ceux de coco le cochon d'inde ont
fait changer les gens en agissant sur la
maine il est vraiment trop mignon
[Musique]
tu es dans une montre croyable aventures
gaffe tu regardes tu veux rester hors de
ton plateau trop longtemps si on ne peut
pas réveiller et bien sûr
alors maintenant je vais la retrouver
ça risque de très mal finir j'avais tout
arranger cette était invisible rêves les
plus fous
dreams au cinéma de sa cote